Time Magazine has named Vladimir
zielinski and what it called the spirit
of Ukraine as its person of the year the
magazine said it was honoring the
Ukrainian president for his role in
leading his country's resistance against
Russia's Invasion
Russia's President Vladimir Putin has
acknowledged that his warn Ukraine could
turn into a quote long-term process he
was defending the war to his personal
Human Rights Council after the Ukrainian
military allegedly carried out a series
of drone attacks against targets deep
inside Russia Putin went on to say that
he would not mobilize additional troops
for now despite setbacks on the
battlefield
like many parts of eastern Ukraine this
Farmer's field is now a Battlefield
despite recent gains by Kiev soldiers
say an influx of Russian reinforcements
is halting their advance
the enemy has become very active
their attacks have intensified their
Aviation is more active there are
continuous air intelligence missions our
positions were shelled all day yesterday
their unmanned aerial devices were in
the air all day
foreign
Villages people have been living without
heat electricity and water since the
start of the war more than nine months
ago
people jump every time a missile strikes
sometimes
I'm sad sometimes it's so scary the
whole house is shaking
it appears her Village will remain a war
zone for many months to come
in an address to his Human Rights
Council Vladimir Putin warned of a long
conflict in Ukraine
for our part there can only be one
response fighting consistently for our
national interests and so we'll be doing
exactly this
nobody should ever count on anything
else
while Russian troops continue their War
Ukraine is gathering evidence including
thousands of Munitions experts hope they
may one day be used to help bring the
Russian leader to Justice
is an advisor to the Ukrainian foreign
minister and she told us what she
thought of Putin's statement that he
that the war will be a quote-long
process
we do not have other choice as except
fighting and thinking and we know that
it is lensley uh processes uh and in
Russia they called it from the very
beginning special military operation and
today Putin called it war and I think he
called this
um this war this way because even in
Russia they uh they prepare the people
for this understanding that these losses
they they they cannot be losses of
special military operations special
military operation and like any military
operation should have some time uh
indicators uh but here they they cannot
win and they don't have any success so
they finally started admitting that This
Is War and obviously for us ukrainians
it doesn't really matter how long it
will take because for us it's a matter
of our survival so how it doesn't matter
if we will have to fight three months or
four months or even a year just because
this is about our you know lives it's
about they they want to heal us and
destroy us here
now our correspondent Mark sander joins
us from Keith Max what do you make of
what you've just heard Ukraine doesn't
seem at all intimidated by this talk of
a long and grinding wall
right so I think most ukrainians aren't
really concerned by the the labels the
Russian president uses for what he is
doing here be it special military
operation or a war that's domestic
politics um for the ukrainians here this
clearly is a war this does not change
the facts on the ground ukrainians have
been dealing for more than nine months
now with missile strikes with artillery
shelling with occupation with terrible
war crimes being committed there
um some large parts of the country still
under Russian occupation and ukrainians
are determined to fight back two days
ago the Ukrainian president made an
appearance at the front
Ukrainian Armed Forces Day and say that
in a year's time
Ukraine would be fully liberated all the
Occupy territories including Russian
Annex Crimea but it is a difficult it's
a difficult task
um there's still severe fighting going
on there's strong fighting going on
around the town in bahubal for example
at the moment where also president
zelinski said every meter counts at the
moment the Russians have managed to take
some suburbs there there there has been
fighting and attacks on nine regions
that were struck last type of artillery
shelling and the town of
just to give you an example 10 civilians
were were killed by by Russian fire
Russia has been sending an Iranian
shahedron so the fighting here is still
going on but ukrainians are determined
to resist and and to eventually in the
long run win this war
now NATO's Secretary General has also
again warned about the months ahead in
the war tell us more about that
right so uh NATO section against
stoltenberg said that Russia is trying
to to to freeze the war I'm fighting
fighting in a winter is difficult and
Russia itself has been dealing with some
setbacks here clearly this did not go as
as the Kremlin had planned this was an
up this was supposed to be a war that
would last only a couple of days now
it's it's it's going into
more than more than nine months so um
what we know is that Russia has been
fortifying areas at their National
borders Russia is seemingly also quite
unsettled by a recent drone attacks of
ukrainians in um that I have not been
claimed that I have to add here but a
drone attacks on their national
territory so Russia is now doing
everything to have some issues with
replenishing stocks with sending new
soldiers to the front so they will do
anything to to buy time to freeze the
conflict and to continue fighting
perhaps another law larger offensive in
Spring
correspondent Max under there in Kiev
thank you Max